économie environnement énergie au social
et
le développement durable à la réunion
c'est maintenant
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter un
éco gestes pour éviter le gaspillage de
nourriture à la continuer venez je vous
montre
c'est beaucoup trop pas étonnant qu'en
2010 au collège nous avons jeté plus de
150 kg de nourriture par jour
pour éviter le gaspillage vaut mieux
prendre une petite assiette qu'une
brosse et si on a encore pas on peut se
servir
comme le montre ce drapeau qui flotte à
l'entrée du collège depuis juin 2009 le
collège jean des sme est labellisé éco
école au collège mendès nous incitons
chacun à adopter des éco gestes pour
qu'il y ait plus de solidarité entre
nous pour améliorer notre cadre de vie
et pour respecter l'environnement
je peux économiser jusqu'à 140 euros sur
mes factures edf comme un gitan les
lumières en quittant la pièce aussi que
l'ordinateur la radio la chaîne et le
téléviseur quand ceux ci ne sont pas
utilisés jaillir les pièces en faisant
des courants d'air le matin et on est et
je ferme les volets du tire les rideaux
alors vous voyez préserver
l'environnement c'est augmenter votre
pouvoir d'achat le conseil général ag
boula développement durable et vous
économie environnement énergie au social
le développement durable à la réunion
c'est maintenant